last week
[Music]
okay
um oh jesus what the hell just happened
so i went around here and there's
nothing here we still don't know how to
work
these things we don't have anything
to use so i guess we go back the other
way this was just a little safe hud
it's very dark for me so if it's dark
for you let me know
well i guess we're going back inside
which is not what i wanted to do but i
guess we know what
oh good my trusty knife
there
he love fishy now she'll have a fishy on
a little fishy dab don't have that
i killed the fish
i don't know why that made such a
ferocious sound
when the boss comes in
look i'm a vegan in real life so let me
let me do this in game
thanks are they just going to keep
spawning
or is that all of them
i got an achievement for that by the way
great ones here our boys together as one
in reverence
we call on thee within the endless dark
to deliver us into fate's hands
as the midnight moon rises on black
wings
so we make the sacrifice and await the
light as the midnight moon rises on
blackberry
we await the light at the end in
life and in death glory to mother
miranda
hey remember me i almost died up at that
castle
tell me what is going on around here
how can a man be almost dead
that's a question for the wise
you know what i mean and i still haven't
found rose
where did mother miranda take her
you're too late or maybe
almost too late the child will be
sacrificed
life for life what kind of sick medieval
[ __ ] is this
she's just a baby the crests of the four
bloodlines
may open the path you seek
will you please stop talking in riddles
i just want to find my daughter
it's only original if you don't know the
answer
she is annoying wait a second
that looks familiar umbrella hey hey
wait
well it'd be cool if you got to see
mermaids
okay so what did you say the crest of
the bloodline
will give you what you seek or something
like that so
horsey mermaid
flower knives sun moon
house beneviento house heisenberg
house mario houston etresque
right so
we just gotta kill
four of them no or something i don't
know but i've taken down halstimitresk
anyway
surely
do i know any of the other names i feel
like i might know heisenberg yeah that
is not the guy
who i keep calling van helsing because i
know nothing
um i think that's him
i might be wrong probably wrong
i have a key
i still have no idea how his hand just
magically came together again
probably just roll with it
oh wow
feet whoa look at long toenails
if only i could jump in this game i'd
definitely try to scale this
do you also have long toenails you do
what is it with
long toenails
guess they can't oh there's another one
there i guess i can't get clippers that
are tough enough
oh it's all four of them
there's two pathways
thank you very much crap
oh whoa
do you mean
uh that's really not good i thought i
had
okay can we make some no
i can make some sniper rifle but i want
my shotguns
it's not fair no i can't even make that
i can make one of these and mine do i
really want to though
no i want to make shotgun
oh foxy
maybe i can do this is that red barrel
is that a red barrel i see
that's a red barrel no it's fricking not
oh
jesus
oh jesus
where's he going he's coming
oh no
here is
i'm already
i'm just gonna stay here hopefully
you'll come to me
come to mama
give me stuff to make shotgun shells
please
where was that supposed barrel that i
was shooting at
can i get down there oh there is
something down there
oh but there's there's definitely more
of those things
and i don't know where to ask for it oh
what i can't jump down there oh
okay
oh i cannot see but i can hear
where is it it's here somewhere
can you hear it it's one of those wooden
oh it's right underneath me
can use this
i need the top of it i guess
which i don't i have this dirty flask i
have no idea what that is
everything sounds like it's growling at
me
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
no i don't like it
when he comes
nope can you come out here please
i don't want to fight you in there
and i'm scared because there's another
entrance right behind me and i don't
want to be bit in the back
i need my shotgun for this
how are you not dead
oh my god right needs need to be better
be better
but hopefully i'll find some shotgun
shells
or something that i can make them with
okay
did you drop anything
how about now
yes only three though hmm
i think i'll still keep them
ah okay that wasn't so scary
what i need a little key
i don't think any of these keys gonna
work
the wind whistles are so good
where do i find this tiny key
any of you guys have a tiny heel on you
tiny key
the altar
there you are i had a feeling you
wouldn't right right
yeah it was all worthless
is that so i assume you've picked up
something of value
not sure if it's a value but oh
why you have your daughter right in your
own hands
what what are you saying
[Music]
take a closer look
i did say it look like a fetus but is
that a heart i don't know now
head
no don't freaking drop it on the floor
it seems to contain her
head
no
roses don't say another word
this this is impossible this just can't
be
your daughter's essence is still intact
her powers are truly unique
oh she's just like uh who could even do
this
she can be saved you know saved
from this are you insane there's a house
with a red chimney on the western side
of the village
go and seek out the man who lives there
then we can continue our conversation
quit holding out and get to the damn
point
you don't have to trust my words
but do you have any better options
your choice the customer is always
right after all
he'll pay you if i find out this is a
lie
[ __ ] joker
hmm
ah yes yes
okay so we're going to bring your head
back to life
right oh hey jade
thanks for coming you you indeed
um okay can we
sell something yes we got some skulls
[Music]
feel quite bad doing this i don't know
why it's like i just
feel bad oh i can summer fish
no i should sell already should i
yeah i probably should should i
yes yes i should what why
why is gamers do we always want to hold
on to things that we should really be
using or like selling
and then by the end of a game we'll just
have never used the thing or sold the
thing
and we've just made the games harder for
ourselves but anyway
um yeah standing on my fishies
i knew there was a reason to kill them
and that's
that's about it i don't want to sell
this because i feel like it goes to
something
so i'm not going to yeah because it's
combinable
elegant yet horrifying
oh it's a common ingredient maybe i can
use it in something
i'm gonna sell one and then see if it
ever comes about that i can use it for
something because it says it's a common
ingredient
oh lady dimitrisk beautiful
even in death that waistline yes
you have
au revoir all right what
which way should i go first there's so
many doors there's so much option
hmm we don't have anything to put on
here maybe the flask
oh oh
oh okay so we're gonna find flasks and
all the different
what the hell that was weird
there was like a person going into a
head brace
that was strange
guess this is the only way we can go
even though that blatantly was the right
key but okay oh look where we are
back here
apparently there's something we've
missed in here
what the hell where did all this come
from
this wasn't here last time we came here
operation date 2.9
2021. oh
uh recorded by nh
arrived at site no so 11
35 arrived at site no sign of
ew or rw that's us and that's author
1210 infiltrated village engaged with
number of bioweapons
found evidence of me but madora's
location is unknown
established based in church
plan of operations search laboratory
analyze mold samples and infiltrate the
factory
damn
i don't know whether to be comforted or
to be more panicked
probably more panicked it's quite nice
to see some technology though
in this world
okay i don't need to say it again
um so was it the gate up there that i
was looking at
oh there's two i can go this way as well
why can i hear chickens are there
chickens around here hello
chickens chickens
sorry i gotta sell you i need more stuff
for my guns
can i kill you
oh i'm so sorry
but i need more stuff for my guns
oh it's just told me to give all my
ingredients a duke
oh i'm sorry i just need more stuff on
my coast
right
is that all i came up here to do
slaughter chickens i
am the worst oh no there is this
just a lot from the other side is that
an elevator
it goes down interesting
okay so that's all that's in here there
is that as well i want to know how to
get in here
the chickens would have done the same
thing to get more guns i like to think
so i like to think so make a steak man
i want to get whatever the hell this is
maybe one day something will fall on it
and it will shut it down and i can get
it
okay this looks
promising
the key won't fit
moving up then
have i not been in here before
oh my god a freaky ass teddy bear
i saw you
how the hell did i not come down here
before
i don't know but i'm very glad i did now
even though it hasn't helped me progress
but i got myself a teddy why have we got
a teddy bear
oh it's valuable okay
thank you very much
nothing to do in here
[Music]
just a scary monster eating goat
nothing up here either is that oh there
is a house
have i been here before
i'll know by things that i can pick up
so i haven't been in here
uh-oh is this gonna lead me out to the
other side
oh [ __ ] jesus christ
i don't know what one to use
thank you
yes oh my shotgun is beautiful when did
it look this good i just don't think
i've noticed
hello
nope don't like the music turning back
i'll have to go there eventually when i
jesus christ
oh yeah there's nothing here anything in
the toilet for me
let's have a little poop a little scared
poop a little nervous
okay hello
oh that was easy nothing for my
shotgun
scary for no reason game
oh sorry uh-huh
i'll leave you alone i can't close the
door again sorry oh yes i can there you
go
give you some privacy right
we're progressing
probably move this somehow
hmm
more houses locked from the other side
i oh like how i can't see inside until i
walk inside it's
really unnerving especially when there's
drips of blood outside
but there's nothing in here well there's
blood in the hay so
maybe i don't want to be playing in the
hay
okay we see we're right down here
but it's not good enough
i guess we gotta enter this place that
says don't enter don't we
great
what the hell
is that some sort of test subject
look out the window oh i don't like this
don't like this what do you mean
look at the window i don't want though
oh 0704.
now [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] shitty
oh thank god
it's getting me oh
i forgot what it was this is a crow here
i'm sorry i'm sorry headphone users all
right
i'm
sorry
okay what was it again
oh seven oh four maybe it's
a four or seven i don't know one of
those two but then isn't this
yeah there's more oh four
oh seven but then what's the last two
what are the last two hmm
looking out the window
are there any other clues around here
that i'm missing
so any number on here
nope nope nope
oh hello hello 070408
ym that's my first and middle name
jasmine may made for me
the game knows uh 070408
i7
oh let's
hmm
try this bad boy
ah
yep i agree
let's close those doors oh [ __ ] sake
oh jesus christ
come on both of you both of you oh no
should really be using my new gun but
okay well that's that
lovely and
should we replace this with our new gun
i don't know because i have
pumped it out so
let's just quickly try it
pumped it out pimped it out pumped it
out that doesn't really make sense
hey how they were just all waiting for
me
thanks scanners i read your comment
earlier
i'm not just like a psychic genius
i wonder if i can use that thing that i
got
no okay
is that door open now probably not
hello thank you
no more surprises
yes this is creepy i thought we were
going gonna collect another
cute teddy bear but i guess
i guess not
okay this is just here for spook factor
got it
gotta go nice nice
am i going to crawl onto this ethan
excuse me uh
[Music]
oh wait no i wanted to try my new gun
i just automatically switched a shotgun
every [ __ ] time
excuse me there's nothing here
rooftops rooftops
okay maybe i can sneak
maybe i don't have to
no scrap for me
hey this is where i came this is where i
started eh
i think i just heard a pig
oh yeah that was what i think it was
foreign
i did hear pig i didn't want to kill
that pig though
i mean chicken fishes
you started it sorry
i hit my butt
i mean it's so bad too bad for the baby
love how um jump scare yeah
i've screamed at a freaking pig how low
can i get
is this
i've been here before probably
yes ethan i see i see the big bad boy
it's okay yasmin's here we'll shoot it
in the head in the head
and it's still coming oh god it has
wings no it doesn't that's an axe
oh it has no head
this gun came with a lot of ammo i
appreciate
that's a lot of goat's heads
can we play with them
they don't oops what
i think there's more dangers
i can hear ah
[ __ ] jesus christ go on
like this way there's too many of them i
can't do this oh my god
no no no no that's not how you aim oh my
god
[Music]
did you reload yeah you did okay good
boy
wow how did i do this
[Music]
ah
this needs faster reload
but it's doing good
i am inside i am safe
locked on the other side
nice i should really use my puck bombs
more i just
don't i i actually just forget that i've
got them most of the time
like if it's not in my shorthand
i just don't even
think about it
[ __ ] christ what the [ __ ] are you
oh god okay wait pipe bomb
quick please chuck it please run please
and again
and run please
did that do it no
eight nothing easy
i'm quite glad i didn't use those pipe
bombs before now
hello nope locked due to missing
homeowner
well not anymore fish
wait which way am i supposed to go okay
i can go up that way
done this way it's not really anything
either
me just have another hand
hmm what's up on the reef
a well wheel well wow wow
wheel that was terrible
i think i'm so disappointed in myself
nice wait
that's it right i can jump over this way
oh and then i can unlock the door
i love having animals engaged especially
in horror games it's like
a little sweet moment something alive
that is going to kill me
but i'm killing them so who's the
monster now
wow
oh this is a fancy toilet
definitely fancy it's got a crystal on
the side
oh hello
don't worry i'm gonna go back to
investigate the other house
i mean that's through
but there's something i
saw did i not see something
yeah ladder
i feel like the werewolves
it'd be cool if i could like be up here
and then maybe see
umbrella or something in the distance
walking
is there nothing nothing was there
nothing up there
oh right of course get in the house
of course
hello
straight back up like that no
what even were you eating other women
down here
what's in here
oh the winged key is just a single piece
three more parts are needed to make it
whole this makes sense this makes sense
why i was getting confused by other
doors because they do look alike
because they ah
they have different parts that just slot
onto it
oh hell yeah i can combine it
nice damn it better see the duke again
yeah
i can't believe we have to see him again
much rather spend time with him than
anyone else i've met in this game
nice pipework
okay
now i'm gonna go check out that house
due to missing homeowner maybe i should
see if i can make some more stuff
buy stuff of course i mean shotgun
shells
do i want to make one of these
i don't need it
what's this oh look pig hell yeah
where are you there you are
wait hold up i'm not using this one
there's definitely going to be something
in here
i wouldn't be all ominous like we can't
find the owner
because he's turned into a oh my god
it's a freaky doll
it's not creepy at all
really i don't trust i think something's
gonna happen when i go outside then
whoa i don't trust it
it's gotta be up here
oh it's tempting me inside though look
at that lovely breakable box it's like
come
in come in oh also musicians
yes please to whom it may concern
due to the luthier's long
absence i am keeping hold of his house
key
please find me if you need it ah i'm
gonna have to go and look for a key
aren't i uh regards joseph simon
benevientos gardner did i pick up a key
okay so where would a gardener put a key
let me in
in the doll
we can't even look at it
wooden animal body i need to find
the head okay it's just
i need to find the head somewhere
where would the gardener put the key
hmm i guess i'll find out another time
in here it's kind of ominous
no
okay
well we have a lockpick so i'm gonna go
and pick this one
hell yes always needed
how was it did you learn anything
i found these feathers now tell me how
to fix this like you said you would
settle down first you must use that key
and collect all of your little roses
flasks
where are the rest of them there are
four in total
you have the one and the other lords
have the rest
lords
mother miranda is the cold calculating
ruler of this village
four lords serve under her
the first you've already met the lady
demetrius
the second lives deep in a valley of
mist the doll maker
donna beneviento
none of her playmates have ever come
back from that dangled estate
the third is moreau a being of twisted
flesh that lives in the reservoir past
the windmills
it is said that he is not the only
monster that lives in those waters
the fourth and most dangerous is
heisenberg
he works in his factory on the village
outskirts
and the project let's just say parts of
the human imagination are better left
alone
so i haven't seen that second one yet i
don't think have i
the first one looks freaking terrifying
i don't want anything to do with dolls
uh okay
what's a real weapon what what's all
this about
louise's heirloom
it's a hidden treasure
beniviento's gardener
beneviento's gardener so the key must be
around here somewhere then
if you truly wish to save your daughter
you must first gather the four
flasks i'll do you a personal favor
i've marked the lord's locations on your
map
some treasures still lurk in this
village
i'm sure each one will prove of great
use to you
why are you doing all this why it's all
part of our first-class customer service
please do come again soon oh
he talks like he's a chain
you wish to make a purchase yeah yes i
have you
find some quality ingredients and bring
them to me
hell yeah
slightly increases health slightly
increases permanently
[ __ ] yes i'll take that damage taken
when guarding decreases permanently
health increases permanently
yes um health
increases health slightly increases
health increases
health greatly increases
maybe i'll just keep hold of them
until i get some juicy game and then
i can greatly increase my health
oh i can do movement speed too
okay just need to look out for some game
have a wonderful adventure you too i
mean
okay
ah okay so anything else we can do
down here before we move on into another
section
is my question
i mean we'll probably end up back here
at some point anyway
do we have anything for the wells yet
oh yeah of course we got a wheel wheel
your trust don't trust
hey that can go on our toy we've got the
bottom half to this
okay good
where are all the wells
um they'll probably tell me on the map
there's one over here
i feel like it's dangerous being around
the church now because that's their base
don't trust it don't trust it don't
trust it
oh god necklace
thank you very much
uh yes i've also what
how do i open these boxes is there
a certain key for them there's more
chicken here
we need to look for game though
how did i miss the chicken
louise's heirloom should we try and go
and get that
we're doing side quests guys side quest
time fun time
trying to pick up all the things uh
please don't say this more freaking oh
there's chickens down there
and there's a well at the back of there
please you'll see this werewolves hiding
in here
i don't
that's not even a werewolf
[Music]
everywhere
jesus christ
stupid things
sorry piggy
i'm sorry i think you have to do this
sorry i must sell you
the big freaking about me the big head
about me
oh
this is one really
healthy pig it won't die
jesus for a second i thought this wasn't
gonna oh it's quality meat that's why
quality quality
okay i hope we get something good here
oh i feel like a bad's happening
what are these things
yeah we got a pipe bomb i guess i won't
complain about that
okay so what are we looking for this
should be some sort of treasure box or
something
oh hello
i suppose it rounds
what's these boxes
okay
wait can we go back inside
is there a safe room in there
not from this side
no it looks like we can't or
no we can't we definitely can't
chickens you're no
longer watching resident evil you're
just watching
yes kills animals
for permanently increased health
and speed and defense for health mainly
[Music]
mum
uh
uh
there's got to be some stuff this way
any wells any wells
oh yeah
i've started to trust the wells now
our relationship has developed do i have
a lockpick
pipe bomb block pit i do
okay because there's something to lock
pick in here so might as well
is that where
i cannot see anything oh it's in the
actual house next to it right
what can be locked picked you can
nuts
um okay let's get the
maestro's collection
although we just went down here so i
don't know why
ah
that's in that house we couldn't go into
isn't it
fair enough then fair enough we can't
get that one
and that's why we need to go into that
place okay
okay well then
in that case
that's apparently still stuff to get in
this house and this one
i'm going a long way
this is still stuff to get in this house
yeah apparently i haven't gotten
everything
what am i missing
angry ethan
that got it
should i bother going into that one
nah can't bother
as you wish so
i got some very good meat but i don't
think
i want to use it no game give me
leaving so soon well yeah cause i don't
have any money
right
oh
necklace with key
key
now i'm very confused
what's the key to
it's up to that house is it
is there something else that was locked
that i couldn't open
all i can think about is that house but
that can't be it
hmm i was not expecting to find that
i can find oh i can combine this
yes
if it's just looking window sharp away
a necklace stone and a wooden goat
all for you oh where did you get your
hands on such a thing
now i just need to find out a good deal
if i say
origin of this key
pixelate says that small box you
couldn't i guess i never found the key
one small box
unless it's this
does this even have a keyhole it doesn't
does it
i wonder what this is it says something
on it it's like a gravestone
when you came from the castle there was
a small box that you needed a tiny key
for when you came from the castle
i think oh i think i i think i know i
think i know thank you thank you thank
you very
late
i'm getting fire on my legs
and here you think
you right
and there was also
can we put the well wheel into this
maybe
no nice try nice try
so where is that chalice that i just
picked up
a goblet
oh okay so that's when we have the full
key
oh wait oh no we can't open that door
either can we
this door up here no that's the full key
no
yeah we need the full key for this one
up here
okay let's carry on
so
well this is ominous
wait guys who am i going to now am i
going to
oh no no
[Music]
i hate dolls so much
but if you find a doll's head this is
good because we need one
to go without our body oh i'm getting
shivers already
just thinking about it dolls are so
creepy
have you guys heard about that place in
mexico where
it's just it's like an island
full of dolls and it's supposed to be
haunted because apparently like
a young child ghost lives there and
therefore people leave
dolls to keep her entertained
and it's just the scariest thing
sorry i'm moving at uh a slug's pace but
oh that shot
i'd use that for the trailer
which way do we go
can we read this
i feel like i'm just going around in
this circle here oh yeah
why could we go up this way then game is
there nothing to get
no secrets i can't even read this
okay
well that's creepy
yep let's run
ethan what
killer it's mia wouldn't let me
ethan come with me there's something i
have to tell you
mia you're not she's not real
rose feels different
ethan you have to fix her i'm trying
what the hell is this
everyone leaves me even wrongs
i don't want to be this can't be real
she's dead isn't she i don't know i
don't trust it
she's not dead is she but that's not her
i know that much
is that a life-sized doll
oh it's just
normal dolls beneviento
freed from the binds of flesh she now
walks the valley of death
1987 to 1996
sam what a short life
is there going to be some sad kind of
backstory to
this villain they lost their
daughter am i losing it
no hello
what's going on
okay can i have a picture back please
that's the only one i've got with me
about fireblade
oh no
there is no letterbox on the other side
of the store
oh sorry sorry you were talking to me
you said give up your memories
i'm not pushed down
oh great
oh great oh great oh great which way am
i looking
come with me ethan what
i don't want to
i feel like i missed something with that
flicker i felt like i should have
been facing the other way
ethan don't care
whoa oh guys that's beautiful
there's some really cool moments just
visually in this game i really enjoy it
that's so nice
wow
quite something and i gotta say
whoever lives here you are brave we know
who lives there but i've forgotten their
name already but
you're brave it looks like it's about to
collapse at any moment
keep a lookout for the groundskeepers
key
donna is who lives here thank you thanks
a lot
so
nothing is falling off
i think i can hear a wooden aha there
you are
hold up i don't want to use this
well donna knows i'm here now for sure
ah yes puppet shoe
how ominous
oh it's not a puppet shoe it's it's just
string
oh there
there it is so is is this donna or is
this
donna you guessing this is donna
i don't want it i'm gonna go into this
door
over here because it's open
and this is anything you can pick up
here
now i'm going to go into this door
because it's open and open doors are
inviting
oh i can't go inside
okay then i guess can i do this
oh i can't smash donna's windows
some sort of sorcery going on here
uh okay fine i'll go into this door
hmm
that's a nice big sofa bed
well it's it's a nice change to not see
blood in the cups but
dirt why or is that just coffee stains
because
i understand the struggle with coffee
stains
i don't trust that doll over there i
feel like i'm gonna turn around and then
turn back around it's gonna be looking
at me
but no it's not okay
i feel like i should respect
don't hate me
oh god oh this house seems to go on
forever
i don't know where to go
just keep going forward
someone needs to really spend some time
redecorating
hey where am i
nothing here this is where it came from
no this is somewhere else that's lots
okay
okay where am i now
cool can i watch something can i put
something on
oh please
maybe i just need to find the um
alkaloids of mountainous plants
well that's good to know thank you
i feel like this section of the game is
really lulling me into a full sense of
security because
nothing is happening there is no music
there is nothing to loot there's nothing
to really
go off of if you know what i mean like
when there's a lot of
things to lose you're like okay
something to kill is coming up soon
but there's a there's nothing here to
indicate
anything so
or if you love old book scanners remind
me at the end of the stream that because
i will show you one that i found in a
cherry shop
over the weekend i'm very proud of it
it's uh edgar allan poe
oh i was just saying there's the music
but
got some irish chickens going down here
maybe we could be friends with this
person uh
maybe i had them all wrong
is that a pregnant lady on her side
that's a bit strange to have but
you know everyone has their own tastes i
suppose
i feel like i shouldn't really go
without a gun in hand oh
[Music]
thanks for following kate karen 59.
release your inner irish okay
this is weird this is just a weird
scenario that's happening here we have
the
happy music and the creepy dolls
ethan's audibly terrified
and i'm not because i've been lulled
into a false sense of security this is
this is all very
clashing oh
also is that a typewriter over there
[Music]
what i don't want to be your dad wait
where's my gun oh what the [ __ ]
no oh god they did
they took my gun they took my gun
okay so this is like a dipetto
what are you doing
am i using this leg as a weapon or
oh
i thought ethan was just gonna start
going
with a little wooden foot i mean i can
see him doing that
sure let me have the ring please
blood covered ring
oh my god it's mia i've only just
noticed this
is this a doll of mia
oh her eyes are squiffy
oh i need to do something
i need to cut them i need something to
cut them okay
let's have a look at the eye
okay
feel like a surgeon
[ __ ] i should have saved oh god what's
happening
oh my god
what the hell is all of this
i'm gonna say before i move on
i'm so weirded out by all of this i love
it um
so was that mia's voice
wait why do i need to know this wait
nope
ethan i keep going to like move it
around but you can't do that
okay it's just three eyes
closed
oh that's locked great
and we need something so has this done
anything
can i get her otherwise no
it's got to be forward it's got that
weird thing on it
oh examine mouth
what do we want here
i need some kind of tool to get it out
all right okay
three closed eyes
oh her eye then something needs to go
here
okay
okay we're understanding
that was a bird right a bird in flight
yeah
okay i don't know whether to save and
finish for today or
we'll take a look through the store at
least
what the hell this room just doesn't
look like it belongs
oh look it's a it's a resident evil um
seven throwback right
then
nothing in here
there's got to be some tools in here
that i can use ah
i miss my knife
surely
not tools no tools
infectious waste autoclave bag
tools tools tools
where could the tools be
just imagine ethan crawling on the floor
looking for tools
i need something
a blood covered ring a winding key
then obviously the silver key
just doesn't look like we can actually
interact with anything in here
aha apart from this
yes shiny shiny
is it actually the wedding ring
i guess oh
05 29 11.
i think i remember oh five
29
11.
and that is where we're leaving it
wish i could play on the piano so
thank you so much for uh
joining me today it's been a pretty
damn good episode i really really
enjoyed it i hope you guys did too
um
[Music]
no [ __ ] jesus christ
[Music]
thank you so much for watching i'll
catch you again next week
at 8 30 p.m
on a thursday have a
dare evening and bye